made a deep fake of myself to deceive my
audience and it totally worked I could
be Nick the studio manager look I'm Nick
the studio manager right now and what's
crazy is how simple this is becoming one
of the most common methods of deep
faking is using a computer process known
as generative adversarial networks or
Gan this process is like taking two AIS
and putting them in competition you tell
the AI to make one image look like
another and then the AI goes away and
does its best AI number two looks at
this image and is like this sucks what
went wrong here and then it tells AI
number one what went wrong why doesn't
it look like the target image so then
ai1 goes back and it fixes all of its
mistakes and it tries again it presents
the new image to ai2 and ai2 is like
it's slightly better but it still kind
of sucks here's why and it gives it all
this feedback this feedback loop happens
over and over and over thousands and
thousands of times until you get to the
point where you've got an image that's
very believable it's like amazing